hello good evening my name is Tom
Wickersham I'm the manager the
mysterious bookshop
and I want to thank you all for joining
us tonight for the launch of Kevin
George's whole city and supporting your
local independent mystery bookstore
Kevin Joyce is an award-winning criminal
justice reporter for Newsday and he is
the author of one previous book the
triangle a year on the ground with New
York's Bloods and Cripps his new book
hell city tells the true story of two
unlikely kingdoms teenage cook here with
us from Baltimore the capitalize on the
chaos of the riots following Freddie
Gray's death to steal 100 million
dollars worth of pills and launched a
drug empire and it's star review book
list called kill City a remarkable feat
of discovery saying that with raw
language and violence
it paints a bleak and grimly complex
picture and issues a siren pole with
poor societal change and now please
welcome Kevin Joyce thanks so much for
having me guys and thanks for coming
it's an honor to be here can I read from
the book I think I talk to many of you
during the reporting of the book before
and after it took me I spent about a
year over a year essentially the last 20
months in and out of this world but a
hard year in it living and breathing it
while I was working at Newsday I was
writing about dart web drug market
encryption how drugs moved on on online
we just move this up a little bit and I
use that sort of as a training ground to
learn about the kind of technology that
some dealers were using and
all the men just to give you a little
background on the story I I first I
talked about this in in the book I first
got wind of the riots and the looting of
the drug stores from a tipster
acquisition resource who I've been
working for my first book the triangle
and he wouldn't actually talked me to
that book but I we had talked about
collaborating on something else either
another story about his experience as a
Bloods gang leader in New York or
possibly even a book about his life so
we had struck up a correspondence and
had a semi friendship and when the
rioting broke out he immediately alerted
me and told me to get to get down there
and he was specifically interested in
the pharmacy rulings which at the time
wasn't really on anybody's radar we knew
who pharmacies were getting wounded but
we just thought it was part of a larger
you know and he said everything in that
area was being looted and so he brought
my attention to the pharmacy readings
and he he told me that was part of an
orchestrated effort specifically to
graphic because the drugs in these
pharmacies and so I spent about the next
year
tracking even after I was done with the
book I kept going I'm still going to
some degree looking and tracking what
happened to those pills and other drugs
that were stolen from those farms there
were 31 pharmacies and methadone clinics
that were officially according to the
DEA looted during the riot that's only
the official number they were also based
on my reporting my reporting show that
there was a number of millions of
dollars worth of heroin pills and other
drugs that also changed hands among drug
gangs during the chaos many gangs in
Baltimore has many of them the biggest
of which is the black guerrilla family
gang known as BGF vgf and other gangs
sort of went to war during the write
they viewed it as a period of where
power could be power was acceptable in
the underworld and things work for grant
right a lot of gang members actually
help defend businesses but others use it
as an opportunity to exploit and to gain
power in the underworld a pecking order
okay and so the book is not only about
the rooted drugs but also about the
drugs that change hands among gangs drug
gangs that were feuding over that drug
those drug corners ready so what I'm
going to do is talk about I'm going to
take a little bit deeper into the book
rather than throw at the beginning and I
sort of take you into the heart of the
epidemic as I experienced it in in some
of the inner city neighborhoods that I
was reporting in one of the reasons that
I wanted to write this book is because
there's so much attention paid to the
opioid epidemic in rural middle-class
and upper-class white communities the
white aspects and epidemic gets a lot of
attention almost exclusively don't get
almost all the attention on the fact is
we can go to Baltimore right now we
could go to East New York right now we
go to Harlem right now and find many
many people shooting up or using pills
who are not white who are not rural
middle-class people this is an epidemic
that affects all income groups all races
ages demographics and that is something
that's largely a book look look past in
the media I think in part because it's
easier for reporters to go most
reporters are white I'm white I'm a
reporter and you know I'm speaking from
experience in most newsrooms most
reporters away and I think white
reporters feel more comfortable going to
white neighborhoods to write about white
drug addicts and that might be a
controversial thing to say but that's
been my experience and so I think if you
saw more people of color in newsrooms
you would see this aspect of the
epidemic represented more fairly in the
press anyway I wanted to cover that that
aspect of it so I'm going to talk to you
a little bit an area in Baltimore called
oxy alley which is actually a very small
stretch on Pennsylvania Avenue but it's
a place where I spend a lot of time
writing you got the attics there and
this is a place where many were some of
the looted drugs and many other drugs
ended up
they call it oxy alley on first glance
it looks like any other blighted Street
in West Baltimore filled with vacant row
homes discarded liquor bottles and
addicts tumbling out of the corner
carry-outs looking like zombies for
Michael Jackson Thriller video but a
closer look at this rundown stretch of
Pennsylvania Avenue reveals some more
troubling something more troubling for
nearly every vacant opiate addicts are
getting high on rooted pills city
product - such users Keisha Jones 23 and
Terry Augmon 21 are holed up in one of
those roasted roach-infested row homes
boiling down a batch of looted pills
into liquid form Keisha's six-year-old
son Moises sits in the corner playing
with his head struck while the women
friend since high school
speculate about the quality of the drug
they're about to inject going to be real
nice Keisha says melting the oxycodone
with a lighter and spoon while Terry
readies the syringe these been black
diaries 40 milligrams I just hope
they're as good as the Hollywood says
Terry who's recently learned she's six
week pregnant pregnant with her first
child she hasn't seen the baby's father
her ex-boyfriend
Tyrone Moxley and five I got to make the
most of it today because I can't be
falling around pills no more Terry says
these bis are my send-off toasted he
gives memorable names to all its opiates
brands that change every few weeks and
vary based on the type of drug and
dosage f/16 hollywood's body Mors yellow
cakes mike tyson's black dominoes and
red tails were all the rage in april in
early May it was Pink's Blue Angels and
dark nights every addict wanted now its
Beyonce's and black ivory they're
clamoring for them gbgs boys didn't let
us down yet have they said Keisha who
like Terry
first began abusing pain pills earlier
this month procuring them from bgf
member trained Lockwood I'm sure they've
done right by us with these two she says
another vacates along oxy gali there are
addicts just like them people snorting
and shooting opiates from dusk till dawn
many of whom got their product from
Jimmy masters dealers before pill City
came along just the interject for a
moment Jimmy masters was the business I
write about him
as part of a crew that was going to
battle with pill city over drug corners
and territory within Baltimore the
concentration of drug abusers on the
street is among the highest in the
country casualty casualties of the
ongoing wave of urban opiate addiction
overdose and associated violence
ravaging America's inner cities with
little notice from wealthier enclaves a
few outside the game venture dollar
actually oxy alley or streets like it
doing them as places quote beyond
redemption and quote says Christian for
Baltimore homicide detectives who's
investigating a number of killings in
the area you come here for one of three
reasons to buy drugs to sell drugs or
because you just don't care anymore and
don't mind dying Sheehan says the only
other excuse he says is your homicide or
narcotics detectives addicts along the
alley tend to agree I [ __ ] for pills I
steal for pills I break into houses for
pills whatever I need to do get to get
my pills I do it just like everybody
else around here
because Vanessa Jackson 37 who snorting
a pair of bikes three houses down from
Keisha and Terry just as a series of
gunshots ring out in the distance
that's our soundtrack jackson jokes the
former beautician says she'd never
touched anything harder than marijuana
before the riot taking heat of the
lesson she learned watching heroin ruin
the lives of siblings cousins neighbors
and customers at the beauty shop where
she wants to work after everything got
so crazy around here with Freddie gray
and all that I was feeling real bad
Jesse Jackson explains
I heard vgf touting cheap pills saying
they're they're as good as heroin but a
lot safer so I did the stupid thing when
and texted them from then on they bought
them every day long as I got cash or I'm
down to have sex since then Jackson's
lost her job seen her longtime boyfriend
and their relationship and been arrested
multiple times for drug possession but
the thing is I can't I still can't stop
using she says five houses down for more
Jackson's getting high Roderick has 44
has just finished injecting two melted
down oxycontin his drug of choice now
that till City is supplying him with
discounted painkillers by the pocketful
I used to use H he's talking about
heroin but H is a street drug you know
he said like an ugly brokedown car
that has who spent about fifty was
spending about fifty dollars a day on
pills by oxy oxy to drug like a Mercedes
Benz something classy if you can afford
the classy one like you buying the one
that's broke down a similar analogy is
drawn by Derrick curry who is currently
spending about $50 a day on pills and
heroin sold by Hill City he says he'd
always thought painkillers were quote
mainly for white people people with
little money and good insurance because
folks like me can't usually afford them
indeed studies have shown prescribers
prescribers are far less likely to give
opiate painkillers to African Americans
due largely to racial bias it was always
hard to get my hands on them curry says
the pills they were scarce but that
changed after the riots he says pills
ain't never been big as heroin around
here and till sit until til said he made
them big say Perry lots of people
switched from heroin to pillows out to
diluted pills on sale this has always
been a heroin town no Baltimore's been
America with America's heroin capital
since the 1960's registering the highest
capita addiction rate of any large
municipality in the country as recently
as 2014 that year the local department
of health counted at least 60,000 drug
addicts in the city as many as 48
thousand of them addicted to heroin by
some estimates one of every ten
residents living in the city is a heroin
addict and even that download Amin says
curry given its long history with heroin
addiction Baltimore in 2015 is in many
ways the natural epicenter of America's
inner-city opiate scourge says Kristen
Marx a DEA agent quote if the white kid
dying in his bedroom in the suburbs is
the symbol of is a symbol of the first
wave mark says continued quote oxy
allottee on oxy alley is a symbol for
the second end quote but hope it's only
part of the problem
she says the April riots laid their
obstacles faced by Baltimore's most
vulnerable residents poverty gun
violence social isolation substandard
housing vacant properties failing
schools unconstitutional policing and
over incarceration but they also made
many of these problems worse leading to
diminished economic activity surging
crime an influx of looted opiates and a
corresponding surgeon
action it's not just happening in
Baltimore either across the country new
oxy oxy alleys are cropping up with
numbing frequency turning blighted
streets into what Marx calls quote
boulevards of pain the people overdosing
in these areas are mostly impoverished
and mostly black records show among them
a 25 24 year-old hairdresser in st.
Louis raising two kids on her own a 20
year old short-order cook in Chicago
with dreams of attending a major
university a 46 year old janitor in
Milwaukee with five children to support
and an adult education teacher in
Philadelphia with dreams of moving to
the suburbs in kanzen Chicago New
Orleans Cincinnati Detroit Atlanta and
other cities dozens more are entering
hospitals rehab clinics and more
freezers every day quote do I know I'm
probably going to die from my addiction
absolutely
end quote system heiress Winton Appel
city customer living in New Orleans no
lower 9th ward the same neighborhood
ravaged by Hurricane Katrina in 2005
start quote but right now the pills are
what I need so I keep using end quote
Keisha Jones and Terry Ogden who have
never travelled outside Baltimore City
were unlucky enough to be among till
city's first first customers like other
new users they'd heard about loopy Luna
dope yet selling at discount prices and
thought why not see what they're about
Keisha recalls the drugs had to be safer
than heroin women assumed sins quote
that junk is strictly for lowlifes and
fiends and clothes
Keisha remembers thinking but pills if
the price was right and they took the
edge off the women saw no need to
abstain I thought they would make me
feel better
says Terry scanning her scar covered
odds in search of an untapped pain and
lord knows they had it's the best
feeling you know because it makes you
feel so confident so at ease it makes
you feel like everything's right as
Terry elaborates on her love for opiates
moyses her son still treated in the
corner calls out the Keisha can we
please go mommy he says growing tired of
sitting in the damp dark bacon the women
are so caught up in preparing their oxy
for injection they'd forgotten all about
the boy not that they'd mind using in
front of him
by now Keisha says he's used to it not
yet love
she tells her son I'm busy I'm just
going to read a little bit more and then
we'll wrap up I just want to get you
guys a little bit more of a taste of
this from a sort of a macro perspective
zooming out as poor black residents of a
violence plagued inner city neighborhood
both Keisha and Terry fall squarely with
until City target demographic Keisha is
a single mother living well beneath the
poverty line while Terry typically
resides in a women's shelter they worked
hard time at a discount clothing store
in Baltimore snorting snorting or
injecting 10 to 12 pills a day in the
employee bathroom I think maybe I'd have
gotten some help by now Terry says if I
knew where to start if the friends were
living in a more prosperous neighborhood
too specific to suggest they'd have a
significantly better chance of getting
treatment baby shows most
government-funded outreach and rehab
programs and us inner cities are
severely underfunded meaning a poor
black opiate addict is less likely than
a better off-white one to get the help
he or she needs experts say
Baltimore's health commissioner dr. Lee
Nolin highlighted the problem in
testimony to the US House of
Representatives Oversight and Government
Reform Committee describing the
difficulties faced by inner city
residents looking to kick opiates I
remember well my patient the 24 year old
mother of two who came to the ER nearly
every week requesting addiction
treatment when a former practicing
physician recalled she would be told
there was nowhere to go that day or the
next and will be offered an appointment
in three weeks time because she lacked
housing and other support supportive
services she would relapse one day her
family found her unresponsive and not
breathing
by the time she arrived in the ER it was
too late for us to save her and she died
dr. Marcus Elgin a Baltimore based
physician specializing in addiction
treatment says the dearth of quality
rehab options in inner cities is quote
just one of the many ways black opioid
abusers are treated differently from
whites suffering from the same disease
in white suburbs and rural spaces there
are shortages too but there is also
outrage at those shortages not so in
poor communities of color
he said Elgin seeing the impact of
so-called riot pills and heroin
firsthand not only on addict
at a well-known Baltimore Hospital where
he's a document residency but also in
his own family
elegance estranged father Morris Elgin
63 died of an overdose overdose in late
April 2015
his tick town apartment two weeks later
Morris's wife Shanice 56 committed
suicide with a mix of vodka and opiate
painkillers
later a teenager Elgin mentored would be
wounded by a BGF jugman
in Baltimore's Penn North neighborhood
why is there despair a treatment for
black suffering during this epidemic and
for the people suffering from related
violence in our communities Elgin asks
for whatever reason the white addict is
more often seen as unwilling and it's
the white addict is more often seen as
an unwilling innocent victim of doctors
and drug companies and that's colored
the way society using the victims people
suffering from disease people who need a
second chance but black intercity opiate
of users especially heroin addicts quote
are still seen by politicians the media
and the public as being somehow
complicit in their addictions and
therefore not diversion deserving of the
same sympathy as whites el djem says
it's a staggering double standard when
you think about it Hank quote Elgin
who is african-american says racism is
just one factor contributing to that
rare treatment also a play is quote the
lack of political influence among poor
blacks living in drug plagued
neighborhoods and the limited number of
treatment options in those places when
compared to white communities
the doctor says quote both of those
factors mean there's less still
visibility for black addicts and
therefore less awareness and
corresponding equity in society Rita
Wexler New Orleans physician
specializing in addiction treatment sees
another culprit black market pain pills
these days she says opiate healing
organizations like toe CD aren't just
distributors of stolen drugs they're
purchasers to the beach you get
franchise in New Orleans for example
serves as the kind of clearinghouse for
pharmacy robbers looking to unload their
liquids hall's says Wexler Eric after
ripping off a drugstore a pepper trip a
perpetrator can sell pain pills the bgf
or another gang at their street value an
arrangement that's termed pill city is
one of the largest known sellers and
buyers of stolen opiates in America well
when the first wave of opiate addicts on
their postal
Clyde shoved off by law enforcement
crackdowns and government regulations
they switched to heroin since it offers
the same highs pain pills but at five or
ten bucks a bag is a lot cheaper says
Wexler quote pill city city essentially
turned that dynamic on its head they
made tells affordable to poor minorities
even as whites were increasingly being
priced out of that market switching the
heroin and now vgf are the guys you come
through when you when you have product
that you want to unload while data
compiled compiled by the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention to
suggest whites who get their pills from
doctors are dying at a higher rate than
blacks CDC records federal autopsy
statistics law enforcement filings and
public health data from America's ten
largest cities indicate that opiates
sold on the black market including
stolen drugs peddled by pill city are
killing African Americans and higher
numbers than whites quote with regard to
overdose deaths caused by a look at
opiates black users are suffering
disproportionately based on what we're
seeing in African American communities
right now says Elgin quote that we don't
hear more about them speaks volumes
about the dialogue surrounding addiction
in this country when the data only
reflects one side of the story
only one group gets the media attention
and financial resources journalists in
the united states to focus on white
opiate users quote to the detriment of
blacks who are seeing more resources
funneled to wider areas says Christina
Keller an addiction counselor in
Cleveland Ohio where dgs has flooded in
poverty pockets of the city with pills
and heroin it's not being done
maliciously rather because wealthier
rural and suburban white communities
know how to make their voices heard when
it comes to opiate abuse Keller says the
squeaky wheel gets the grease
in this case the grease is news coverage
and the government funding that follows
it she said as an example of one-sided
coverage Keller cites of January 2016
New York Times article on mortality
rates which stated quote researchers
repeatedly speculate that the nation is
seeing a cohort of whites who are
isolated and left out of the economy and
society and who have gotten ready access
to cheap heroin and prescription
narcotic drugs and quote talk about
isolate and left out of the economy
that's how black communities have felt
since the country's inception exclaims
Keller who is white there's no question
she
said white opiate addicts are suffering
and unprecedent wage due to some of
these same conditions but we cannot
ignore the fact there are
african-americans living this way - my
question is where the stories about them
and quote as for pill Sydney many of its
associates say they're grateful for the
lack of press scrutiny quote if our
customers will write that [ __ ] would be
on the front page says damage one pill
city member that would make what we do
but that would make what we're doing a
lot harder thank you thank you I you
know I wasn't going to read that much
but I wanted to give you guys I wanted
to contextualise if you guys and not
just give you paint a picture I wanted
to put give you some of the data to a
lot a lot of the book was pulling
records and breaking down data from the
CDC's wonder system a lot of it involved
pulling over those records from all over
the country so there was a lot of
footwork with a lot of paperwork - so I
tried to get that in here - just to
bring a story home from a data
perspective and not just an anecdotal
perspective so anything you guys want to
ask me open the questions about the book
anything else
sure Alan about when you referred to
East New York because my kind of just
anecdotal impression was that hills
hadn't really infiltrated non-white
neighborhoods of New York City is that
right pills have infiltrated but more so
heroin so what I tried to do in the book
is really I hate to separate pills from
heroin from any other opiates so I view
it as I think public health experts in
the country are viewing it as part of
the same problem you know if you're hot
if you're addicted to the opium opium
molecule you're going to be addicted to
heroin you can be addicted to pills you
can want to shoot either one so in East
New York mostly I've seen heroin not so
many pills but mostly heroin but they
are there's this market - pills - but a
broader market for heroin in East New
York and that's really what I wanted to
burn home if it's not just pills in
these locations it's heroin - and the
people buying these and the people
selling them all view it as part of the
same market because it's the same
chemical addiction but the tools still
tend to be more of a white people thing
because they get originally from the
doctors yeah what I found from the book
is that most legally person legally
prescribed prescription opiates for
opiates go to White's
my researcher that a large percentage of
illegal opiate painkillers of being sold
to Black's much larger than is
recognized in the official federal
statistics that's partially a result of
toxicology reports being more sorrow
being being conducted more frequently in
wider neighborhood neighborhoods that
tend to have more money more resources
to conduct conduct full complete
autopsies and toxicology
there's a lot of factors like from a
illegal street dealing perspective I
found that this is having an outside
hope that killed pills and heroin are
really affecting African American
communities in ways that we hadn't
really anticipated and that's the
federal public health data hasn't
necessarily reflected which is why I
thought it was important to get this out
there yeah you mentioned that overdoses
are notable in the african-american
community and I walked in a bit late so
forgive me if I miss this but um I was
just wondering why is it because
quantities are being consumed at higher
doses it's the end in these instances or
is is that medical health is less
readily available or what could be it
well I in terms of overall opiate
overdoses I don't make the argument in
the book that it's more prevalent in
communities of color and minorities but
I do make the argument that it's
prevalent and much more prevalent than
reverse likely and public health is
generally or or media coverage
especially and so I think part of the
reason that we don't that we're not
hearing a lot about this part of the
opioid epidemic is that the narrative
has been created that that it's a white
Laurel middle class upper class problem
you know what Newsday I wrote a
connoisseur
about people who a white families a lot
of times we'll provide a picture of
beautiful young white girls they'd like
to put on the front page of the
newspaper and that's a trend you seeing
in the press and that's what you can
seen for the past decade but the flip
side of that is there's a lot in
communities of color there's also a lot
of people dying and it's not as using
yourself or them for whatever reason the
reporter can get out there using get
that nice picture go on in front of the
paper and it's it's just become part of
this narrative that's being steamrolled
and I'm sort of what I want to do is
sort of just correct for that mario's
and bring another element into it
forgive me the mission because wasn't it
Egyptian wonderful prevalent at deported
yeah well I think the point that you're
referring to is in the ten census tracts
with the highest levels of opioid
overdose rates 53 out of 100 census
tracts with the highest levels of opioid
overdose rates are majority minority
communities that doesn't mean
necessarily that minorities are
overdosing at a higher rate in those
communities but those are communities
that are majority minority so and those
are places where I saw the most severe
impact and that's something that I think
is just not being addressed in the press
and really by public health researchers
and I'm hoping that it will the book
will bring more attention to that issue
yes thank you you got very intimate with
a lot of your subjects here in their
homes for these really incredibly like
trying moments how what was your
reporting process like you know to meet
people and get into their lives really
same thing I've always done which is
just put myself on the line go up to
people talk to them tell them Who I am
when I'm interested in and really just
hang around until somebody tells me
something and I've worked with you I've
worked with a lot of people in this room
and so much what we do is just you know
putting yourself out there in a
situation that not definitely isn't
comfortable and it's not only safe
and with this book it was definitely
taking to the to you know to the extreme
with that when I first got to Baltimore
I was lucky enough to have a source who
was in the gang world who was a I guess
you could call it a retired Bloods gang
leader and he was able to vouch for me a
little bit with some of the people I
interviewed if I hadn't had him as an
intermediary I wouldn't have been able
to connect with anybody and so through
him I was able to get some of this stuff
and be inviting to some of these places
and then once I started meeting people
were just sort of took on a life of its
own like any story you start figuring
out what the Attucks concrete expected
you know what the dealer's go you
started hearing about pills that were
looted from this pharmacy and you hear
about them in this neighborhood of this
neighborhood you go there you go there
so I was just different around Baltimore
whenever I could when I got off work on
the weekends I would be there and when I
was that news day I was working on
stories about and this is the other part
of the story I think it's interesting I
was working on stories about encryption
and the dorte web if we hear a lot about
now but these get some of these gang
members so I write about in the book or
among the first dyno in America to
incorporate encryption and dark web
drug-dealing into the inner city drug
market now that might sound
sophisticated it is to some degree like
it's also as simple as just using Apple
messenger or signal right or using any
other in Christmas program some two of
the young men who are depositing the
book were actually programmed software
designers and programmers so they
created their own messaging software but
they also used encrypted software that's
out there already like signal and Apple
messenger and others so a lot of my
reporting was going online it was done
through email so something encrypted
email their communicating with people
who were selling these drugs on the dark
web so it was something new and when I
was in it I you know I thought it was
such an explosive story yeah you know it
was unbelievable being what I was seeing
and you know so I wanted to and I felt
that it needs of these to be outfit and
so the other reason for that the other
reason I think it's important that that
story gets folded at that high tech
element
told is that I think that's the future
to large degree of drugs young that's
all then how we're going to see product
move increasingly we're not going to see
so we're still going to see corner boys
we're still going to see people on the
corner but the smart play right now if
you're drug dealer is to use your iPhone
which I talked about in the book is
being the most powerful drug dealing
tool ever created
encryption is the communication so it's
not no longer matter of just serving
drive up traffic with heroin or coke or
pills a lot of this stuff even-even in
really poor areas is being done now
online because everything's being done
online so and I so I'd say you know I
did a lot I get a lot on the web and
then just a lot of just running around
try not to get killed mostly yeah
Christina so you bring up a very good
point about the lack of minorities in
New Zealand
how do you - part question yeah how do
you think that as reporters we get to
bring the voices of the minorities who
are overdosing on these on opioid
addiction to the newsroom whether it's
on the front page or even a brief how do
you how do you think we should better
execute a pitch to our editors also do
you plan to take your book to like local
community people or even councilmen to
show them like listen this is an issue
we need to bring not just free clinics
with clinics that actually to do more
health healers for people in their
community
absolutely so I'll take the first part
first in terms of telling these stories
I think newsrooms in America you know
it's no secret that they're primarily
white and I think editors need and
reporters need to make it a priority and
say listen we're telling the story and
we put the pretty white girl on the
front page and we're talking about
overdoses here but what about the poor
communities here we're acting like this
this story isn't only a primary is only
only a white problem which is ridiculous
to think that the opiate of the opiate
the opioid epidemic is only going to
affect pretty white girls okay
it affects everybody the the molecule
does not discriminate whether you're
black like you know male/female American
Indian in being Jewish Muslim it doesn't
matter so the idea that we're making it
I think editors need to realize that
part of covering communities fairly is
also covering addiction fairly it's not
just you can't just cover economics
daily you can just cover education
fairly across all demographics you also
need to cover things like addiction
because cross all demographics because
it's killing more people than anything
else in this country killing more people
than car accidents okay it's killing
more people than guns in any case in
some categories so I think they need to
I think editors need to listen to
minority voices in their community they
need to take a broader of they need to
have a broader perspective when it comes
to looking at issues like addiction and
talked about it in totality and not just
go to the communities where they're
comfortable which are often more loyal
more white more comfortable communities
and I think we I think the key is need
to send reporters out the more
communities that aren't represented in
the media period right so that might be
mean sending reporters out to a
neighborhood that reporter might not
want to go because there wasn't shooting
there yesterday today or danger so
there's drug corners that's our jobs to
go to those places and tell those
stories right and as newsrooms
increasingly become Ivy League being a
newspaper reporter used to be in being
it used to be a working a working-class
job used to be not like it is now and I
think you would have I think if we had
that approach now where people were more
willing to go to places where they were
uncomfortable you'd see more stories
like this so I think that's what we need
to we need to be more uncomfortable and
editors need to be willing to make that
reporters more uncomfortable those are
the stories that we need other questions
shall see it
and so we are obviously if the dealing
is together and work a lot together and
a lot of what I do reporting wise I mean
in Brownsville most a time South Bronx
it's like 80% in those communities
you're talking about I think a lot of
the perceptions and I'm not saying this
is an accurate picture but I think the
perception is you know when it's drugs
and any sorts of communities it's going
to be perfect it's going to be like you
know that's the term we use per beam
it's going to be gang-related so we're
not going to touch it necessarily
because it's per payin gang-related in
this individual that may be as overdose
has a rap sheet that's like five miles
long
he's got 53 priors and it's just you
know how do we write something nice
about somebody that's died of this
horrible addiction when he's been
involved in so much crime and I think
it's not fair it's not fair at all but I
think what happens a lot of these
suburban white kids they get caught up
in their own kind of drug world they
might not have the rap sheet maybe dad's
paid it off maybe they got lawyers but
who knows like you know I'm just a siz
different but do you see like all these
other it's the addiction but it's also
these other factors that kind of play
into it you know maybe you've got like
five weapons charges or something you're
absolutely right as climber boy there's
a lot of crimes lawyers in the room
today I'll tell you what a hell must be
empty tonight good man all the Devils
are here but uh but uh but no I you have
you have a great point and I I'm guilty
of this as a crime reporter as are I
think all of us in our editors to at
what we do is when we get a name the
people a lot of people who follow the
news don't notice when we get a name
generally somebody was involved in a
crime or an overdose or whatever anytime
you see air in the news and for
something that is not good we generally
run them through the through the system
to see what their if they have a rap
sheet right and sometimes when somebody
has a rap sheet or committee
conjure done time editors and reporters
users come propio that's too perfect for
us to cover that's perfect you know that
yeah a couple people overdose on that
blocklist that's perfect man we have
shootings out there it's all gangs and
drugs out there anyway and there is this
perception in the media that we can fit
the fit that those stories could be more
easily dismissed right for whatever
reason and that's institutional and
that's been going on for a very long
time and that's going to be that's going
to require to think differently I think
about that that's going to be like
turning a big ship around to think
definitely about how we approach
addiction and crime and issues like that
and you know and it's also one of the
fact that you could only have so much
stateless real estate when you're
telling a story right so there's the
papers and the TV news want to tell the
most dramatic stories that are going to
reach the demographics with money right
people are going to buy papers turn on a
TV buy advertising right and so they're
naturally gravitating more toward places
with money that a more affluent then
they also communities where maybe they
might not tell as many papers don't have
this high penetration viewership so
money economics reported it as well as
just the mindset that is that has
developed over decades in newsrooms um
we're all guilty of that I think and I
think we need to start thinking about
thinking about it differently and just
get rid of that the idea that that a
story should should get any less
coverage because it's in a bad
neighborhood
well because a man or a woman has a rap
sheet they don't deserve the same
coverage that because they wouldn't
white neighborhoods that's my
perspective anyone hears the contrary
from course yeah
[Music]
from it's a editors point of view it's
more surprising when like you know a
middle-class girl on Long Island
overdoses from pills then when drugs hit
communities where people were kind of
bored with two strikes against them in
terms of poverty homelessness
it may be parents of involvement
criminal justice system so it's not
really a value judgement about one
person is worth more than the other it's
just like a very kind of cold and
calculating news can be tough to change
that I agree with you it is it is a cold
in calculating news value it's ingrained
and I'm as guilty of it as anybody else
I mean this is what we're taught as
journalists that this is the bigger
story Pete Hamill always said the best
story is murder at a good address right
nobody cares about the murder at the bad
address murder at a good address it was
yep right so it's rarer right and it's a
bigger story so what I wanted to do in
this book is tell a lot about murders of
bad addresses and and those stories that
we don't hear so I think it's going to I
don't know if we'll be able to change
that but I think we just need to have
some voices and newsrooms who are aware
of that idea I'm hoping this book helps
propagate that that idea in philosophy
at least at least a little bit yeah what
that was a full gorilla girl before
years one thing that I noticed as I kept
following these stories and i falled was
very close to the prostate will be some
from a rural country town of Vermont and
one thing I noticed as as it gets deeper
people become numb to it because it's so
prevalent and the heart that the hardest
thing is is keeping them unknown if you
want to use that as a term because a lot
of people really going to leave it and I
have a hard time making people believe
that Vermont and I'm actually doing work
in eastern Maine right now and no matter
where I've been I've been up and down 91
up and down 95 I put on you
is one in Maine it's everywhere I don't
think people and it's not enough it's
not and you know and these are not quite
these are like the white working-class
people that live in the nice upscale
places in Darien and that these are the
working men out in the water and their
children and they have no they have
nothing to pass their livelihood to now
because a lot of their men a lot of
their children have this problem and
it's it really is even though it's
technically a white man's problem but
when you go farther out the Eastport
Maine if you find out that the Native
Americans also have the same same exact
problem yeah and and often to a greater
degree because not so much that they're
less educated they're they're educated
enough it's just that it's easier to get
to them they have a problem of addiction
to begin with all right Native Americans
have an addiction problem it's been
great and it has to do you know they
limit their they limit their alcohol you
can take it to bars up there all right
let me pick it up from there yeah yeah
let me pick up I mean every community is
dealing with the out we fall out from
the opioid epidemic this this molecule
does not discriminate it does not
discriminate and we need to stop and why
communities like the ones you're
describing I mean that's raw it's
horrible and that's real not happening
and this so many communities that are
being hit hard like that I just wanted
to bring my small piece of the story
that say hey look like it's not just so
it's not just white families who are
suffering from this which I think if you
were alien landing on this planet in
your googled opiate addiction you might
you could be forgiving if you believe
that it's only affecting white people
because you would just read story after
story after story about white struggling
about white working-class people out of
the drug job market who are turning to
cheap pills cheap heroin I just don't
want us to forget that there's many many
other people out there suffering from
this this same addiction and it's the
hardest addiction I think in the world
to break because it's pure pleasure I
mean the thing that I heard over and
over again is hey
you know you don't know what this is
like when I take this my life was [ __ ]
before Dell taught me when I take this I
am I'm the king I'm the queen there's no
feeling like this and you know it's hard
to kick something that make you feel
that way whether you're black or white
other questions say yeah two questions
um first in like a trump area you think
policymakers will read look like this
and repeat the mistakes of the war on
drugs and incarcerate lots of people as
a solution and second you were just
describing like the euphoria and ecstasy
of taking these drugs did you try any
this no no no I never I never did I've
never done heroin I during the reporting
of the story I consumed no opiate when I
was when I was in college that's another
story like money I like many of us but
know it I mean it's it's it's horrible
and I wouldn't mess with it at this
point in my life because it's so
addictive and I've seen it destroy so
many lives that people's in this room
we've dealt with it there are people who
we work with have dealt with it and it
transcends all boundaries and I just
want even though we know that like
that's that's the boiling place that the
government that the city always like
this addiction transcends all boundaries
you don't hear about the boundary beyond
the white neighborhood so that's what I
want people to hear about the other part
of your question was how I think how is
this epidemic going to be treated
through the criminal justice system well
obviously I think we're now now the
narrative is completely changed this is
well documented that now we you know
okay so before Trump came into office
the during the Obama presidency there
was really a sea change where the
government and the press followed suit
with this started viewing addiction as a
problem as a health care issue as a
problem of treatment at the disease
they've used addiction as a disease
whereas before when we had a ademma
kinetics that affected largely African
America communities like the crack
epidemic in the 80s and early in the 90s
that was at that time the portrayal by
the government by the press following
suit was that hey this is a this is a
gang problem there these neighborhoods
are creating these problems on their own
they need to be locked up it means that
we have to lock them up away the key
that's where the three strikes laws came
in that's where you saw a lot of really
tough tough laws that created that
created the course of real estate that
we have now where we lock them more
people than anybody in the world and of
course when we had an epidemic that
became that became affecting whites in
numbers in massive numbers the opioid
epidemic the narrative changed and I
talked about in the book I think that
narrative change my retort because those
white wider communities have more
political power they have more money
they know how to call a congressman or
get their councilmen or a woman on the
phone and that's something that doesn't
always happen in poorer communities it
doesn't always happen and a lot of times
any when you do reach out it's not the
same because politicians go where the
votes are and where the money is right
and the press does the same thing so so
I think in the trump era I don't know
what's going to happen before he left
office Obama got through a billion
dollars in a funding to fight the
epidemic which is the most that's ever
been allocated toward it and he was
fought through the nail on that and
that's not enough in my opinion and in
the book I talked about a number of
doctors and others who believe that we
need a Marshall Plan to fight opiate
addiction in this country we need to be
pouring billions of dollars into
community programs faith-based programs
addiction programs education programs
anti-violence programs it's all part of
the same problem and and it's going to
take money to solve that and so what
we're seeing I think is we're going to
see unfortunately the opiate epidemic
drop on the list of priorities that the
federal government has I mean who the
hell knows what's happening right now
Supreme Court nominees yeah so who the
hell knows what's going on right now
going on so I think we're all waiting to
see what happens but I'm willing to bet
that the opiate ademma demek isn't going
to be high on president Trump's list
although it should be because he got a
lot of votes in communities that are
being ravaged by the opiate epidemic
especially white communities so you made
a number of promises that he was going
to address those issues so let's see if
that's something that he actually will
address yeah or did you go into thinking
and when I told the story of inequality
and presenteeism health care is in
different communities like how did you
focus and vanaras kind of all
yeah well it's thought it is I went down
to I went down to Baltimore and I
freelanced Authority for Newsweek I was
working for Newsday but I freelance the
story for Newsweek about gangs in
Baltimore and about how they were they
had one of the largest there's dozens of
gangs in Baltimore some small some large
and I was just viewing the rioting and
the unrest and the activism from their
perspective and what they've used but
like I mentioned earlier there were a
number of gang members were actually
trying to keep the peace but there were
also a lot of them taking advantage in
exploiting the situation which was a
situation where police were overwhelmed
the press is overwhelmed and it was sort
of anything-goes it was like the Wild
West in certain pockets of the city for
a limited number of hours so during that
time I just wanted to focus narrowly on
the pharmacy looting and break news
about that because I saw it as a big
story when I got connected with some of
the people who read in dealing those
drugs and I saw that it was essentially
a conspiracy to steal and traffic those
drugs in some of the areas we've been
talking about including West Baltimore
and other pockets of the city that might
my my antenna went off and I said Jesus
Christ this is the biggest this is huge
and then I started thinking about the
socio-economic issues and then I started
pursuing those those arteries of the
story in a way I probably wouldn't know
it happened in any other city I I was
born through it the way a lot of other
people were because I was looking at
Newsday and I was covering the white
aspect of the epidemic and I was not
aware I was you know I knew that that
people were dying opiates in in minority
neighborhoods but I did not experience
that reality of news that the way that
it started to change for me is when my
first book I went to this place called
the Triangle in Hempstead the big drug
there was cold
cracked and but I saw the way the drugs
affected those communities and I also
saw the way opiates were beginning to
creep into them so it was on my radar
when I was in Baltimore and I said wait
a second this is something nobody's
covered so yeah I wanted to tell a story
that nobody had told before and I found
that there just wasn't a lot of there
wasn't a lot out there so it was a
matter of showing up and in many cases
just listening and that's what it
it started a micro very micro focused on
the pharmacies and trying to sell some
stories essentially and freelance and
make a living and then it sort of
expanded and I saw that this was a much
bigger national story at a traveling I
was able to through some of the dealers
who who acknowledged me that they were
involved in this stuff trace some of the
movie drugs to other cities in the
country in other state including in New
Jersey Pennsylvania South Florida
Riviera Beach and so I was able to sort
of my goal with the track he impacted
those drugs as they moved across the
country I only was able to track some of
them but but you know I wanted to show
how something like a pharmacy or
thirty-one pharmacy Moving's looting
could actually have a huge impact on
drug markets on the agency board
any other question one more question
anybody yes
we think you must community around
finishing treatment and adults within
communities but if you were coming at it
from the perspective we're starting from
the game perspective and how this drug
trade involved did you notice any way
within the drugs is this messing with in
the way it works great among bookings
unlike that there may be a way to
interfere there and interesting with
their ability to make it a profitable
evidence wasn't you continue you mean
from a law enforcement perspective okay
men are in general like a trade economic
perspective from yeah I mean from my
perspective I was trying to be
dispassionate and not view it from a law
enforcement perspective or from you know
I wanted to view it just overall I
wanted to take the bird's-eye view that
being said I spoke to a lot of law
enforcement officials during the
reporting of the book who said that
encryption that they need way they need
a backdoor and this is something that
James Comey now we know James coming and
having put out these memos before the
election but before that one of the
things that got the most coverage for
was that he was calling for backdoor
tool encryption for Apple and Android
devices and I think to a man law
enforcement believes that that is where
you cut it off if you have access to
someone's phone after you arrest them
and it's not and you don't just get ten
guesses on the password but you have
indefinite you could crack that code you
know it used to be that the odd that be
that a cell phone was detected is great
is cool when they got a cell phone
everything was in there the drug dealers
world is in there is contacts where he
was where he's going his entire network
now you can't necessarily access that
anymore and a lot of drug dealers know
that and so I think that that's that's a
that's a major issue and that hasn't
been addressed either and in terms of
encryption and how that's going to be
dealt with by the sides going forward so
thank you guys I appreciate you coming
out
thank you here at PCC thank you so much
Kevin we've got the money book for sale
we'd be happy to sign up yeah okay